my favorite thing is photo bombing sorry
Simon some great captions keep it up and
what is Gary doing here because
we thought he would trade off for
Black's night oh he's just given up his
night for a pawn it's this I mean either
this is genius or as a mouse lip he's
given up White's night and also White's
Knight is trapped on this Square so the
question is does Prague even take this
Knight now or does he have something
better
think an issues idea here is to just go
purely on the attack and go all out for
the black king he's hoping that he's
luring the black king out into the open
onto a vulnerable dark square but
computer says it doesn't work
Prague he's got four and a half minutes
can he find the solution can he find the
refutation of White's move and we have
to jump in uh because yeah I was gonna
say it looked like Anish was super calm
in the beginning after making that move
but then he started shaking started
shaking and here anisha's idea he's
given up his Knight if the Knight is
captured then the White Queen steps back
hitting the black Rook